tapis rouge et crépitement des flash
c'est parti pour le festival de Cann
avec bien sûr la fameuse montée des
marches en ve d'ê le sourire d'audreou
et la robe de Monica Bellucci
Christophe c'est le mois de mai en fin
d'après-midi et tous les ans c'est la
même histoire 100 m de tapis rouge
deviennent le centre du monde et pas la
peine de se demander pourquoi il suffit
d'un profil de Monica Bellucci ou d'And
mdowell de Sam Jackson qui se prend pour
un photographe d'une C électrique mais
Élég carnaval du cinéma peut débuter
mais bon sang que ressent-on quand on
monte c'est C anné
marche bon ce sont un peu star hein
quand même il y a pas à dire hein c'est
toujours on y croit on y croit c'est un
rêve chaque année on est obligé d'être à
can c'est comme une drog c'est un
spectacle très agréable et puis après
une fois qu'on est rentré dans le palais
on s'imerge dans le film et pour parler
de cinéma ce soir c'est encore le David
chicotte qui fait le spectacle du film
événement qui ouvre ce 59e Festival de
Can
l'équipe du
tabeé par son réalisateur monsieur
rard avec en bonus don Brown auteur du
polar et jusqu'ici avar en apparition
suivi de près de l'équipe du film que je
pense je n'ai plus besoin de vous
présenter dans le sein dessin du Palais
du Festival Vincent Cassel fait les
présentations l'actrice italienne Monica
[Musique]
Bellucci échange de regard avant que
l'acteur et réalisateur cinépoitier
signe l'ouverture du
festivals-idi c'est parti pour la 59
édition du
Fes